m
merci
[Musique]
de même économique aura maintenu de
bonnes habitudes de nos spectateurs
à la benne
donc les pédales de la
visite à l'adversaire
boumediene
donc vous allez m dos si les novices et
habitat d' une heure et demi les
règlements
de télévision
[Musique]
la manquer
les femmes perdent la vie en donnant la
vie tous les jours dans les
établissements de santé du sénégal le
cadastre sorna qui a perdu la vie à
l'hôpital de louga déçu du négligence
médicale est illustratif de la longue
liste de drames que vivent les patients
au sénégal et les femmes en grossesse en
particulier
[Musique]
les diables et qu'on a ramené en vue
d'amener des
brumes le coût
humain les couleurs a montré dans le
langage quotidien
nous deux donne
[Musique]
parce que
la loi